higher the seat the smart of the fame
which team has the most World Series win
in MLB history the New York Yankees I
believe New York Yankees how many MLB
teams have never won a World Series
three six which teams finished 2023 with
the most wins in the League the New York
Yankees most wins in the league they're
not even in the playoffs oh uh Atlanta
brav which pitcher threw the most
strikeouts in baseball this season they
go with uh re Bryce Spencer shrider how
many World Series have the Phillies won
two two who is the Phillies all full
time leader in home run Bryce Harper is
it Schmitty yeah yeah how many World
Series have the Braves won zero three
four what was the last time Philly won
the World Series 2018 or 2008 2008 when
was the last time Atlanta won the World
Series 2009